alors bonjour à la planète je salue la
caméra numéro 36 y en a trois en studio
il ya aussi quatre autres quatre autres
personnes ici avec moi on va se tourner
vers une autre caméra pour faire un bon
jour à la planète de groupe on se tourne
vers celle-ci tiens voilà
bonjour alors aujourd'hui on a une très
grande émission à vous proposer je
dirais grimpent parce que le sujet est
profond
ah bon oui et on va falloir patienter
quelques instants encore autour de la
table les impatients on commence par
anne marie van bonjour anne à l'espace
autochtone elle avait un petit peu de
temps libre aujourd'hui c'est dj rien
d'autre à faire devant les copains j'ai
plein d'autres choses à faire
c'est gentil d'être venu oui toujours un
grand plaisir
il est invité à l'émission aujourd'hui
mérite de la section anglaise de radio
canada international et bonjour et vous
allez comprendre
au fil de cette émission pourquoi il est
important qu'ils soient aujourd'hui avec
nous les spécialistes d'une question qui
que nous allons aborder en simple
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
même moi je ne savais pas léo gimeno de
la section espagnole latino-américaine
est avec nous c'est l'un de nos m est
notre deuxième mois de maistre celle du
secteur france est avec nous sur le
clavier pourquoi vous dit rien vous avez
pouffer alors c'est marie claude simard
oui alors aujourd'hui avant d'aller vers
le sujet on va aborder de de la sphère
café eu un écho à autour de la planète
évidemment ce qui s'est passé à toronto
on va montrer des images de
l'arrestation ce policier
ken l'âme qui est devenu un héros par la
suite et qui refuse d'être le héros de
cette journée terrible ou dick dit
torontois ont perdu la vie et 14 autres
ont été blessées par un conducteur de
camionnette te fous qui voulaient
faucher des vies comme ça comme ça s'est
produit dans d'autres villes de grandes
villes du monde celui ci est animé par
un apparemment une haine des femmes
apparemment il faudra vérifier sur
l'ordre enquête fallon on a des regards
des les gens passaient derrière
tranquillement sans se douter de ce qui
se passe il a passé les sept dernières
minutes a fauché des gens sur le
trottoir et jambon ne savent pas ce
qu'ils n'ont ce qui est arrivé mais
c'est ça qui m'étonne aussi le voleur
les gens qui lâche
oui mais il y a le policier vert canard
oui oui les gens regardent sans se
douter du pire mais en voyant qu'il ya
une norme la pointer vers un homme
puis sirène qui crie puis l'officier qui
écrit aussi il y avait une certaine au
début mais le policier l'arrêté arrêter
là c'est rien a voire d'arrêter l'homme
il a il l'a au sol il y tout seul ce
policier tout seul
oui alors il est peut-être éviter une
situation encore plus terrible on sait
pas mais en tout cas ça s'est produit
ici mon canada et j'ai pour vous les
dernières images ont été publiées par
sybille ici à quelques minutes à vendre
à des landes c'est j'espère qu'on l'a
dans le menu démission ça s'appelle
vidéo 1-2 terrible alors voici cette
camionnette qui roule sur nous sur votre
toit un extrait de 7 secondes seulement
on peut pas diffuser davantage
on comprend assez facilement pourquoi
est ce que vous l'avez pas dans le vote
tenu à vous laver dans le thé je pense
aller dans le thé vous avez dans la
presse péter paysage au 6 allée dans le
c'est bon ça va coûter on peut obliger
de s'appesantir là dessus sept camions
avec a retrouvé m
on peut partir d'autres oui certainement
mais alors là aujourd'hui on va
avoir le plaisir de parler avec
quelqu'un qui connaît les situations qui
a connu dans sa vie des situations un
terrible qui habite aujourd'hui au
canada va nous raconter son histoire
je vais vous demander maintenant
ensemble de deviner le sujet de
l'émission d'accord alors je vous
connaissez c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne chaque semaine voilà alors
c'est notre vidéo
cinq images est ce qu'on est prêt pour
la vidéo 5 images et cette semaine
écoute je vais laisser la vidéo numéro
trois fait la voix si bien alors cinq
images vous me dîtes si vous pouvez
deviner dans la fin des cinq images déjà
d'édition aujourd'hui c'est très beau
sain
beaucoup de gens canesta afghanistan
pour quoi vous pensez afghanistan c'est
une touriste ah oui des gens qui
habitent dans ce pays
népal pakistan
ouais pakistan n'est pas l'afghanistan
la danse vous êtes je veux avoir la
réponse
voilà vous avez cherché un peu parce que
c'est des images qui ressemble
oui c'est pas nécessairement des images
de guerre qu'on a vu à part celle de la
touriste qui est bien oui et les soldats
alors joué aujourd'hui donc aborder
cette question de l'afghanistan essayé
de la voir avec un regard nouveau
si vous voulez on a parlé des larmes on
a parlé des armes maintenant essayons de
voir s'il y avait pas s'ils apportent
toujours autre chose
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs la réalité vécue
par les gens à part c'est le thème
aujourd'hui je vais vous proposer le jeu
de la grosse boule avant d'aller vers
l'invité mais je dois vous avouer que
tous les jeux de la grosse poule
aujourd'hui comporte une question
sérieuse à la guerre donc c'est pas le
moment de réjouissance mais on a
toujours le plaisir de partager ensemble
nos connaissances de voir si on se
souvient des choses la même manière
alors voilà aussi la première question à
ce qu'on ait la vie des contrôles c'est
encore la grosse boule premier tour
cette première question
voilà c'est bon pour 20 points
en quelle année est ce que michael zehaf
bibeau pris d'assaut la colline du
parlement pour dénoncer l'engagement de
l'armée canadienne en afghanistan
une histoire qui a fait le tour du monde
reagan on va commencer par ceux qui
n'ont pas la bonne réponse 2014 passe
tellement vite des fois on n'est plus
trop sur deux nuls 13ème capteurs
n'avait droit qu'à une date c'était
aussi mais ma réponse
ils peuvent différencier jeudi dès 2015
de luxe d'accord et vous méric loger
je vois tu en 2014 et les quatorze 2014
aussi si vous avez répondu 2014 ou
mettez 10 points dans votre colonne web
ont levé la main
c'est un mari et puis les oléo gmail au
n'empêche aurait pu avoir plus un point
de vente j'avais la bonne réponse
iliad aux deux autres jeux allaient
point continue à augmenter la formule
oui alors on va aller bien d'autres
invités aujourd'hui j'ai donné une idée
de qui il pouvait être mais vous allez
découvrir son identité par le jeu des
questions qui êtes-vous invité mystère
alors je vous donne quand même son
prénom zabi et lorsqu'il vint
s'identifier donna son nom famille parce
que si vous donne son nom de famille
pour aller reconnaître tout de suite
vous êtes afghan d'origine oui voilà ça
commence bien
ça commence très très bien vous êtes
réfugiez vous êtes arrivé comme réfugié
au canada
oui bon dieu ça avance bien aussi vous
pouvez répondre un tu peux plus que par
oui ou par non
ça fait cinq ans réfugié de guerre
pendant pendant la guerre contre les
moudjahidine et les cieux oui à l'époque
des soviétiques dont contre avis malaval
parfaitement dans l'évasion l'invasion
bonnes bases militaires beaucoup
d'informations je me demande donc ça
fait 35 ans qui est le monsieur au
canada
vous avez vous avez été chassés de
l'afghanistan pour dépasser oui on peut
dire qu'on n'avait pas le choix de
quitter étant donné qu' il y avait la
guerre est une invasion soviétique il ya
eu l'apparition des moudjahidine des
groupes radicaux et de l'autre mais vous
étiez un civil vous êtes arrivé ici dont
étaient des civils
j'avais j'avais 7 ans d'accord pourquoi
est ce qu'il est l'invité à cette
émission il a fait quelque chose de
plutôt remarquable il a une expérience
de vie plutôt remarquable et il en
témoigne dans une oeuvre plus tôt en
marquant je vous donne cet indice
l'amène à l'émission aujourd'hui ça va
jusqu'à la wii vous avez écrit un livre
we are on a été un livre qui était prévu
en 2015 la fin de 2015
alors on va on va montrer caroline ne
repas la montre et on va aussi lui
parler bonjour caroline vous et habib
vous avez vous vous êtes rencontrés il
ya sept ans à peu près je pense 9,1 mon
dieu c'est fou comme les gens
regardaient de vieux de vieux écrits
j'imagine est bon c'était un garçon un
peu étrange lorsque vous l'avez
rencontré il n'était pas tout à fait
comme les autres
oui non c'est très introverti qui en
même temps un témoignait d'une grande
dignité de cars dans son attitude avait
quelque chose qui se distinguait
parfaitement en fait québécois moyen
tout en étant très très très réservé une
réserve puis
l'attitude silencieuse assez mystérieuse
qui avait beaucoup de charme et en même
temps qu'ils pompiers qui ont témoigné
de mal être profond
bon j'avoue je vous avais des beaux
moves une façon bien précise à décrire
des choses est ce que vous êtes
psychanalyste vous êtes 6 4 il était là
peu de relation des mails et mental je
travaille juste et en santé d'accord et
il pensé vous qu'il avait besoin d'être
lorsque vous l'avez rencontré change que
oui mais c'est parce qu'il m'a séduite
bien sûr un s'est posée comment vous
vous êtes rencontrés dans quelle
situation
mais on était des voisins ça faisait
déjà un peu pris un nom que j'avais
déménagé dans ce quartier et dand ci à
montréal et caro aussi je pense a pu
apporter quelques mois elle avait
déménagé dans ce quartier là puis un
jour je marchais vers le métro prendre
le métro pour aller travailler
caroline m'avait vu moi je mets des
remarques et déjà le permet sinon c'est
qu'elles sont triés sur son origine que
je me dis peut être un indien et
pakistanais mais d'où il vient c'est
difficile pour moi de le cerner et du
coup ont salué quelques fois et un matin
il pleuvait as you qui je boitais
liberty alors c'est vraiment la porte
voisine alors en perte un travail y moi
j'étais dans la voiture je me offert aux
et au métro mais comment était votre
expérience d'écouté votre pays à 17 ans
puis arriver dans un pays comme le
canada qui est complètement différent
j'avais environ 15 ans et demi quand
comme ma famille et moi on a quitté
l'afghanistan en est allé au pakistan
un duo voyage ça nous a pris trois jours
de route passait par les déserts
élémentaire quand cuillère
la guerre souvent on n'a pas nos papiers
on n'a pas de passeport aidant ces
années là le gouvernement afghan
communiste afghan avait confisqué nos
passeports dont il fallait passer par
des passages juste pour se rendre de
kaboul en afghanistan à peshawar au
pakistan normalement ça renvoie toute la
france
mais là cette distance là on a fait en
trois jours dans des conditions très
difficiles et par exemple un nouveau
visage et aussi éviter les soviétiques
éviter des soldats afghans et les
moudjahidine dans ces cas là notre vie
ou être mettre en danger
alors on a passé quelque temps au
pakistan et par la suite on est on est
on est venu au canada
mais arrivés au canada pour moi c'était
un nouveau monde complètement différent
pour ceux qui connaissent un peu la
naissance était complètement notre monde
je suis arrivé ici dans un pays où ou à
de liberté mais aussi en moi mon choc
c'était la présence des femmes dans la
société québécoise
partout dans le transport en commun dans
des bureaux dans les écoles alors que je
venais de quitter un pays où à ou n'y a
pas grand chose pour les femmes 1 son
cachet et moi j'ai dit que 50% de la
population à vienne est invitée c'est à
dire un homme afghanes sont cachés en
dessous des burqas ou rester à la maison
ils n'ont pas accès à l'éducation à des
soins de santé
c'est ça pour moi c'était complètement
un choc quand je suis arrivé ici au
canada dans un monde complètement
différent si tu es bien vu là bas en
afghanistan est mal vu si ce qui est
bienvenu ici c'était mal vu là
oui des divisions pendant des années
parlez-moi de veau aux hormones ça fait
15 ans atteint ya une fille qui s'assoit
à côté de vous dans l'autobus viens de
vous raconter la scène dans votre livre
oui en effet c'est ça moi je suis arrivé
ici au mois de décembre
donc il faisait froid pendant plusieurs
mois tellement porté des grumes en eau
des études où vous voyez pas grand chose
mais c'est comme les boules quand on est
près d'arriver
mais c'est ça avec le beau temps bon il
ya eu l'apparition aussi des décharges
des défis avec des camisoles avec des
téléphones des premières fois dans un
bus à montréal il ya une belle fille est
venue à s'asseoir à côté de moi
décharger nos bras ou aussi et pour moi
c'était quelque chose à la fois je me
sentais mal à l'aise à cause d un
échantillon culturelle et religieuse
elle n'était pas ma soeur ni ma cousine
lit ma mère parce que jusqu'à la fin
auquel j'avais accès c'était en absence
était ma mère m'avait alors là la
malaise en plus elle n'était pas
musulman dans jal est directement en
enfer mais de l'autre kobly j'avais 17
ans donc j'ai aimé ça aussi humala que
j'ai dit que les mémorials été je vais
rester pour la baisse de ma vie on sent
la tension ici je lui ai demandé à
caroline de nous expliquer il nous
raconte cette histoire évidemment s'il
avait été seul dans son coin sans vous
rencontrez on n'aurait peut-être pas
droit à ce témoignage d'un homme qui à
qui est passé de l'autre côté du mur sur
d'où est venue l'idée à coups de ton
histoire
les fascinantes à ta relation tu as
découvert par découverte des femmes
c'est quelque chose je pense quoi il ya
beaucoup de choses qu'on pourra
apprendre de toi de ton intégration des
efforts d'intégration à quel moment vous
parlez de son ensemble comment arrives
la conversation assez tôt quand j'ai
rencontré de vie quand on s'est
rapprochés que j'ai découvert son
histoire vu de l'intérieur
j'ai fait me non mais c'est
extraordinaire il faut qu'on sache soit
on soupçonne poste que vivent les gens
qui proviennent et les hommes
particulièrement en provenance des pays
arabes ou musulmans on a absolument
aucune idée de ce qu'ils peuvent vivre
dans leur for intérieur parce qu'en fait
les codes sociaux de cette société
leur interdisent de communiquer leurs
apps est est ce qu'ils se trouvent
c'est très mal vu d'en parler alors
c'est là que j'ai remis gtz il faut que
tu écris et pendant même je me rappelle
on avait acheté un livre vous savez à
pattes blanches pour qui avec une bonne
plume pour dire allez comme ans il suit
commencé à l'heure les jeunes et comme
encouragé pendant un bon moment et à ces
bétons de compris que dans ceux dits
parviendrez pas à écrire à cause de la
langue à cause de cette difficulté
d'accéder justement son effet évidemment
vous devez vous fait donc c'est comme ça
que je lui ai prêté mes mots parce que
et je me suis mise à écrire pour lui en
son nom et quand il a lu il s'est
vraiment reconnue et c'est ça a été très
heureux il ya vraiment senti mairie mais
c'est ça alors je sais vraiment se
sépare un truchement du coeur que je lui
prêter mes mots c'est vraiment un grand
chemin particulier pour les aider mais
on parle de ce livre là c'est quoi le
titre
le succès est bien une ville l'évêque
m'a conquis on a d'ailleurs une petite
vidéo pour que le titre reste en mémoire
une image vaut mille mots
alors on a fait une vidéo savons
milliards de mots voici donc le livre en
question
et puis on est aussi allé sur votre site
web et sur facebook sur votre facebook
on a tout cas on a capturé en a volé et
voici ce que ça donne des bases images
et ça fait trois ans maintenant je pense
que le livre est publié trois ans ou
deux ans deux ans et demi et on vous en
parle encore là des gens qui vous écrire
que vous disent qu'ils vous remercie oui
et surtout on est invités souvent donné
des conférences sur mon parcours
migratoire vais sûrement chaque année
des petites conférences aussi dans les
écoles la semaine passée d'une itt nous
est venue l'idée évidemment à marie en
fait oui je voulais savoir est ce que
vous êtes retourné en afghanistan depuis
seules ou en couple
tous les deux au seul couple c'est très
difficile et dangereux en 2000
en 2005 je suis retourné en un pin's
temps avec avec et puis j'ai passé de 3
semaines à kaboul
jusqu'en 2005 j'avais hangar j'avais
gardé encore les images des années 70 en
afghanistan quand j'étais jeune à alors
en 2005 jusqu'à les détruire
c'était c'était deux semaines très
triste pour moi la fois où déguster
content de me retrouver parmi mes
cousins cousines mais quand j'ai visité
un petit pour la ville
quand j'ai vu dentelle et à l'habilité
c'était très très bulot et les
conditions des femmes avait-elle changer
un petit peu ou pas du tout pas vraiment
ça moi j'avais encore les images des
années 70 en 2005 la situation
je les trouvais qu est-ce qui c'est quoi
la réaction de la communauté
garou pakistanais ici au canada à votre
livre bon comme iter gagnent au début
qu'ils ont fait est que par rapport par
exemple juste le titre laissant la voie
à ces mots parce qu'il sert au premier
niveau au mois le titre ça veut dire que
je suis tombé en amour avec le québec
jeu j'étais su séduire on est en général
plus tard en une vie des commentaires
quand même positive qu'ils sont contents
mais au début j'avais des craintes qui
est bien certain temps dans la
précédente
les foi ont dit pas tout dans un livre
est ce qu'il pourrait y avoir un second
livre ou un second témoignage parfois
c'est fort possible depuis quelques
temps en france il ya des filles oui
parce que pour trouver le temps pour le
mettre sur papier et l'anglais moi
j'avais une dernière question je voulais
pas que ça reste sans réponse je joue et
j'ai une vision aux rayons x - je vois
loin
il ya une réflexion dans l'image
derrière vous et on voit comme un
vitrail de est ce que vous êtes dans une
église
quelque part ajouté y at-il autre image
ouais il ya des magnifiques que fenêtres
comme dans une église c'est une photo
qui a été prise dans la saga
il ya une vraie image sélection va
écouter
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation aujourd'hui et puis d'être
venu à radio canada la semaine dernière
je sais que beaucoup de gens qui nous
parlait de votre témoignage de ce que
vous avez raconté eux mêmes étaient
calmes renversé par le fait que oui
effectivement on se rend pas compte de
ce que quelqu'un qui veut s'intégrer à
la société pâle ce qui lui disent qu'ils
traversent
pendant qu'il est en train de se passer
de faire ce chemin vingt parmi nous et
vous aviez donc les mots tous les deux
ensemble pour raconter cette histoire
qui n'est pas terminé on en est sûr
merci beaucoup merci merci alors c'était
habits et naïades zada et caroline chane
à quelque part à montréal non pas dans
une église mais probablement à la maison
des phobies qui me passe par la tête
je pense qu'on ne serait prêt pour
l'exposition pour les images
d'exposition marie claude a été tourné
quelque chose cette semaine et jusqu'au
bout du monde tourné ces images voici la
cafétéria de radio canada
et oui moi j'ai jamais temps d'y aller
je t'aurais tellement fort jamais le
temps d'aller manger des fois des yankee
manger c'est des images d'afghanistan où
je vous parle de jours donc derrière les
larmes derrière les armes le visage des
de l'afghanistan aujourd'hui voici des
enfants qui en témoignent voyez des
sourires
voyez des gens qui qui se donnent
l'accolade et ça c'était une exposition
qui met en avant première ici à radio
canada mais le public
le grand public pourra la voir au
festival accès asie du 1er mai au 27 mai
et on présente ça sourire d'afghanistan
c'est du photographe iranien ahmed
cadène et et puis le vernissage a lieu
vendredi le 5 mai mais s'intéresse que
les gens qui sont à montréal bien sûr
alors c'est un projet de photographie
qui a été amorcée en 2013 plusieurs
années et le photographe l'a simplement
présenter une nouvelle image de
l'afghanistan ce qu'on fait à l'instant
et il ya quelque chose qui est assez qui
est bien agréable et où je vais parler
avec le photographe n'était pas possible
il a cependant encore des lunettes on
entrevues en anglais à radio canada
international à notre service latino
américains donc ça c'est sous le
couvercle espagnol ça c'est pas ça en
anglais avec rufo valencia qui je vous
montrais ça donc ça s'en vient j'ai été
sur la page web
de la compétition tous services
espagnols
voici donc le photographe ya lui sans sa
barbe quand il est au canada et il ya
lui il n'a pas quand il va faire ses
photographies en afghanistan pour passer
pour avoir déjà tout le monde oui vous
savez qui on aurait pu éviter
aujourd'hui autour de cette table une
personne qui a travaillé à radio canada
international qui est du côté de 6 bis
et maintenant c'est élise jacob et
lisait les photographes et elle est
allée en afghanistan donner des cours de
photo à des femmes afghanes ya quelques
années et elle en a rapporté elle même
ses propres photos qui sont absolument
magnifiques
d'où l'idée de tenir des réunions de
production tous les lundis à partir de 6
heures le matin exactement mais elle a
fait des photos vraiment remarquable et
elle a accès à ces femmes là et elle
leur a appris à elle-même tourner le
viseur vers leur vie et vers la vie en
allemagne
cela fonctionne en équipe ici vous nous
avez convaincu en faire une émission sur
la photographie sexuellement canada a
présenté à travers quelque chose sur la
réaction
mcgann quand c'est arrivé au canada
parce que j'aimerais bien savoir comment
on a compris comme un homme à comprendre
comment une femme
à quand un élève c'est quand elle enlève
sa burqa n'est plus à visible une
histoire son compte france et à l'ouest
est l'élément real puis avait même une
collègue qui venez je suis pas susciter
l'afghanistan mais je suis sûr qu'ils
étaient en fête a été amené par ce
qu'est sa famille il voulait la mariée
avec une personne ici monsieur beaucoup
plus âgé qu'elle
elle avait dit non alors sa famille la
régie tpir étoiles à montréal mais il
portait pas de bulle quand on fait un
saut à son pays oui oui je savais pas
tout seul si une fois j'arrive à la
maison dès mon cours de france christ et
arrière puis je la vois ma femme dit une
fille à côté j'ai dit allons mon amour
puis g
bisou à ma femme puis je fais comme on
fait en argentine mais à l'autre et j'ai
dû même bijou à la famille à rester
comme ça crise est complètement figé
puis bougeait pas pu manger sain parce
que c'est ce que j'ai fait du mal
il parlait pas et bibi j'ai dû sortir ma
famille m'a dit ça ça puis après il est
allé me chercher pour me dire payer pas
habitués au contact des gens c'est sûr
il n'y a pas de contacts là bas et on
les savait pas en fait c'est elle qui a
la calmer puis à parler après puisque
c'est la première personne simple les
premiers l'homme qui me touche pas je
pose mon père ça ce soir réaction
normale des gens qui ont vécu comme une
vie opprimés une fois face à la liberté
ils ou elles savent pas quoi faire se
rencontrer à fait peur
oui absolument besoin raconte on se
rencontrer deux trois fois de plus puis
la troisième fois c'est elle qui est
venue m'aider à l'eau il serrait les
rangs des codes étaient différents y
avait pas de danger
sa fonction est de côté à billes dans
son livre il écrit qu'il n'a jamais reçu
de caresses
s'il n'a jamais été embrassée bordé par
sa mère par cesare contact physique est
permis mais parlant de la burqa là j'en
ai essayé une un jour parce que élise
justement en a rapporté une et je
l'essayé jeu les mises et je trouve ça
incroyable que les femmes réussissent à
vivre avec ça au quotidien c'est
étouffant vraiment je me sentais étouffé
puis je me sentais devenir invisible
c'est ça souvent c'était une situation
qui disent le fameux oui et ils sont
tous permettant d'alléger un peu le
temps de l'émission c'est mon travail
commencé ma fonction ici alors je suis
amuseurs publics mais c'est le jeu de la
grosse boule deuxième tour ça vaut pour
combien on va regarder la vidéo numéro 6
combien ça vaut enfin combien ça vaut 30
points imaginer j'en appelle les scores
10 pour un mari 10 pour les aux héros
pour les autres voici la question vous
lisez la question oui ça y est je les
lui remettent
mais les autres sont internet c'est
peut-être pas très claire alors au plus
fort des combats
qu'est ce que ça dit ça quelle année la
présence militaire canadienne en
afghanistan s'élevait à kong un soldat
au plus fort des combats à orry fort des
combats
non je voudrais existe pas l'année je
pense simplement au pire non ils sont
plus toujours là les soldats n'ont plus
fort des combats
combien y avait-il de mise en terre crue
elle est une vie en premier aïd et
j'exagère peut-être trente mille 30
mille avait soixante sept mille
américains mais ils sont allés à 100
milles et vous me dites trente mille
canadiens faisaient partie du lot
j'exagère jamais c'est vrai faut pas
vous fiez donc je change pas mon chiffre
ses 30000 se transmet-elle d'accord elle
s'enlise
de votre côté lui c'est le spécialiste
des questions non non ce parce qu il y a
soixante mille à peu près 60 mille
soldats et voilà dans les forces
régulières borne à toutes les forces
régulières à peu près 20 milles dans
leurs réserves
ça fait 80 milles au maximum à peu près
80 oui moi je sais pas exactement le
chiffre d'abord je dînais 6000 10000 dit
il notre spécialiste des questions
militaires alors marie-claude 2002 mais
il passe de limay arctique votre 6500
ses 1500 en fait il était exactement
alors c'est bon pour trois points
elle est en elle elle commande et khalid
actuellement elle même cette émission
d'une longueur de tête de cheval dont
mais j'ai eu davantage de réponses après
nos deux premiers
j'aurais presque dix ans mais il vous
dit ça nous amène à la question de
tomtom canada on va demander à marc
montgomery de lire cette question alors
enlève la question qui était posté
commentée en français sur facebook cette
semaine après 17 ans d'intervention
militaire étrangère
l'afghanistan est en proie à des vagues
d'attentats des talibans ou de l'état
islamique va retomber
ou alors c'est la question parce que là
ils ont augmenté la présence militaire
monsieur travaille à melun
sega annonce était une non c'était au
moins deux oui c'était il ya un an au
printemps de l'an dernier il a annoncé
comme ils appellent ça en anglais donc
communes comme une vague sur la cela sur
la plage et il est bon c'est pas ça va
fonctionner parce que depuis ce temps là
il ya eu d'autres grandes explosions
centre d'achats hôpital encore récemment
ben oui tous les jours en fait peut-être
même dont on n'entend pas parler c'est
un dramatique va demander on a demandé
l'opinion des internautes voici celle de
monsieur ou de madame ait à mettray ya
c'est pas clair d'où vient cette
personne j'ai fait des recherches sur
facebook et ça n'a pas abouti
mais binoche si je comprends mais
anne-marie vous avez vous allez être
aïta mettrais ya d'abord c'est un sacré
alors depuis 9 1 1
donc j'imagine depuis le 11 septembre
quand les états unis ont agi sans
l'accord de la communauté internationale
ce sont des coalitions sporadiques de
pays alliés qui interviennent ici est là
sur terre les interventions devraient
pourtant toujours être faite avec l'onu
en amont et les casques bleus de toute
communauté en aval
donc ce serait si cette personne suggère
ça serait plus efficace si on avait
l'aval de l'onu avant de se lancer dans
des aventures comme celle là
je suis surpris marque que canada se
soit embarqué militairement pendant kw à
12 ans en afghanistan de 2001 à 2010 on
va pas le dire et 30 à marquer dans
cette affaire là sans que ce soit une
décision de l'onu normalement on attend
les décisions devenues avant de se
lancer
c'est aussi la question de l'otan avec
le défi liste les accords
d'international militaires des échanges
et c'est alors on est on est quand même
allié avec le west américains les
anglais dans l'angleterre ainsi de suite
donc si aux hôtes ont décidé que c'était
une cause qui valent peine donc on a
embarqué
on avait deux doigts de ne pas embarquer
par exemple mais on a embarqué quand
même puis éventuellement c'est devenu
très impopulaire auprès des canadiens
font parce qu'on a senti c'est un non
sens disait à faire la guerre finalement
pas vraiment à faire le changement voilà
donc on s'est retiré à mort donnée à un
moment donné voici troisième question
cette semaine c'est bon pour qu'on va
aller voir que c'est bon pour combien de
points vidéo numéro 8
voilà et puis tiens on va demander à
marie claude de lire la question les
vernis militaires canadiens ont quitté
l'afghanistan en quelle année et ce
après 12 ans de combat c'est assez
facile mais c'est 50 points faciles à
obtenir
alors anne marie 2013 2013 c'est très
bien parce que ça commence chez cas en
2000 à 2 après
[Musique]
allongée de 8 ce que vous dites les eaux
unikin 2015 dit les autres eh bien voyez
les réponses peuvent être très
différents même réalité même média subit
quelques élections me semble que ça fait
pas si longtemps que ça que ces intrus
d'eau annoncé qu'avec elle vraiment il y
avait plus de celle déjà pouvoir
ah bon ballon donc lorsque les
militaires les combattants militaires se
sont revenus au pays il était quand même
je pense notre relation mais sans la
question où les militaires je pense que
ça sans daigner finalement en quelle
année on est on s'est complètement
retirée
bah je vais je vais juste pour la
différencier encore 2016 2016 qui dit
mieux 2016
ajoie est à 2014 2014 la bonne réponse
or et noir attend dé voir si je n'ai pas
de réponse
la bonne réponse c'est en 2014
félicitations j'étais pas loin avec 13
points c'est fantastique c'est 2014
j'ai eu et j'ai gagné tous les matches
et nommé j'ai vu mariko de travailler
hier soir très tard on évite le pire
donc il entend téléphone mais je suis
dans l'embarras parce que j'ai fait
visiter des papiers oui ils ont défait
le fils de harki parce qu'ils avaient
fait une piste ok c'est vrai donc
c'était quand même chaud et même le bord
de cette piste là une portion de cet
endroit et c'est dans le musée national
du canada
kéké votre là où vous habitez je parle
écoutez c'est parce que en 2001 bien sûr
des américains se sont précipités et les
canadiens on a attendu à 2002 avant d'y
aller
parmi les premiers sur le terrain mais
on n'est pas oui en fait la grande
question c'est de savoir si toutes ces
missions la d'armes et internationale ce
ont servi à quelque chose que je pense
que notre invité monsieur habib je sais
pas si je sais pas si web et ixtapa 6068
morts du côté des soldats canadiens ou
des coûts du canadien
les diplomates et puis on sait pas
combien ça coûte et entre 11 milliards
et 18 milliards
les livres se contredisent encore bien
des âmes cas moi mais les statistiques
ne peut même pas se terminer puisque y
en a encore tous les jours mais il faut
se rappeler c'est moi je pensais la
leçon qu'on est tous tous les toutes les
nations qui ont envahi contentait
d'avenir l'afghanistan ont échoué depuis
combien de centaines d'années oui et
puis on répète l'histoire parce
qu'évidemment on n'a rien eu à faire
voilà c'est tout c'est tout ça va pour
aujourd'hui
mehdaoui la comté bret alors j'imagine
encore c'est ce qui me reste en tête
l'admettre les soldats de côté puis
penser à tous ces civils qui doivent
vivre au quotidien là dedans c'est la
présence militaire des amis
internationale pour suivre les questions
parce que la peur c'est de toutes sortes
de côté parce qu'il a peur des talibans
il a peur des soldats afghans il ya la
peur d'être si les dessus par des
soldats alliés d'être dénoncé par un
voisin la ccc une vie une vidéo vide par
en effet d'accord bon donc touche à des
sujets sérieux on a parlé de l'autisme
et ya quelques semaines c'était un très
très grand succès notre émission sur
l'autisme en de ne pas laisser passer
c'est un secret industriel
non si ce n'est pas le droit et on peut
aller sur facebook avoir conduit la
semaine prochaine c'est un sujet plus
léger la semaine prochaine sera portée
sur la santé des questions de des
décisions de vie ou de mort je suis
assez vieux les gens mais elle il faut
profiter de l'opportunité pour dire à
tout le monde en fait sauf le canada les
états-unis l'australie puis quelques
pays comme ça les premières mais c'est
la journée des travailleurs balle monde
oui alors ça c'est les billets c'est la
journée on appelle malades au travail
c'est soit exact très bien que ça plus
d'informations sur need la maladie
[Rires]
chaque fois écouté et merci beaucoup à
marivaux ça fait plaisir
j'espère on va reconstituer donc notre
équipe de rêve tellement et êtes une
partie de l'équipe de rêve d'accord
c'est qu'il admirait voilà et notre
spécialiste des questions militaires
il faut pas trop se prendre au sérieux
merci de revenir un jour derrière et
puis les eaux gimeno c'était impeccable
plan technique je pense oui je pense que
oui très bien vous préparer à dire adieu
à la dernière caméra on ne fait pas tout
de suite marie marie marie claude simard
merci beaucoup pour cela grands gagnants
du jour on l'applaudît l'applaudît et on
applaudit la planète d'avoir été à
l'écouté mais également à la semaine
prochaine